la fabrique opéra fait appel à une
dizaine de corps de métiers décorateur
coiffeuses maquilleuses costumière ou
encore éclairagiste pour gérer
rassembler tout ce beau monde il faut un
chef d'orchestre patoche et le directeur
de production
il veille à ce que tout se passe bien
puis ce faire les plannings sait faire
que tout soit là au bon moment
voilà c'est l'homme à tout faire que
tout soit là au bon moment et qui ne
manque rien mais c'est très varié voilà
ça va je vous dis d re des repas à la
livraison des costumes à la voilà à tout
tout tout ce qui peut être dans l'ombre
de ce spectacle les balles et on les a
enlevés parce qu'on m'a dit content
aujourd'hui un jour de la générale avec
30 du mélo le metteur en scène et
clément joubert le chef d'orchestre il
prépare les effets pyrotechniques
une nouveauté pour tout le monde non le
tir en salle que dont parlait fret était
pour les mettre un peu plus offrant un
peu plus loin là bas on sait pas ce que
ça va donner
donc c'est effectivement la découverte
dans quelques instants à faire des
premiers tests
et puis ça va être la découverte mais on
est très très très excité par le parlent
par le projet puisque d'un moment ça va
partir de partout et ça va être ça va
être formidable forcément et de la
pression patoche on a surtout quand
l'opéra ali professionnels et amateurs
c'est d'ailleurs le principe de la
fabrique opéra et ça fonctionne c'est un
ensemble justement qui est très
hétéroclite de gens qui se serait pas
forcément croisé naturellement dans la
vie de tous les jours mais du coup on
s'enrichit tous les uns des autres de
ses de ces rencontres est finalement
l'idée c'est qu'effectivement tout le
monde est au pied d'égalité c'est un
opéra coopérative dans le sens noble du
terme
on est tous on a tous une part
importante à prendre dans cet opéra
chacun nous à la prendre chacun doit
s'en saisir et ça mais l'idée c'est
qu'on réussisse c'est tout à quelques
heures de la générale on procède aux
derniers réglages dans les coulisses la
tension est à son apogée
et puis le spectacle enfin le résultat
de plus de sept mois de travail
récompensé
[Musique]